Madame President welcome thank you very
much for uh being with us this morning
it is a pleasure and honor to uh to have
uh you here with us um it has been a
very uh difficult it is and it it is
still a very difficult year but it has
been a very um complex year also that
the one that we have spent together um
in your speech on the State of the Union
you have rightly saw made the point of
what the European Union has managed to
achieve during these uh years but also
which is the work in front of us that we
still have and unfortunately uh that was
before the present crisis that we are
going through and this is even more uh
relevant the work that we need to uh uh
to go together um as you can see the
title of our conference is about uh
security uh that was s before the uh the
events of the 7th of October but
unfortunately uh the title still stands
very very true and we are more than
willing to uh get from you um the sense
the direction that you see for uh the
European Union especially for us for our
ambassadors around the world um warm
well words of thanks to you in
particular for uh um uh what you have
managed to uh um uh how youve managed to
steer uh this complex machine during uh
this period your leadership has been
strong and felt and this is something
that I think we all need to have so
without further Ado thank you very much
and um please the floor is
yours good morning thank you very much
uh Secretary General dear Stefano
ambassadors heads of representation
heads of mission ladies and gentlemen
dear feder it's a pleasure to see you
here today I'm very glad to have this
opportunity to exchange with you again
today and to thank you all in person for
the work that you're doing across the
world indeed it has been now four years
that I firsthand had the chance to speak
to you when uh this commission took
office and back then we spoke of the
changing nature of politics and
geopolitics and of the instabilities and
risks that lay ahead of us well much has
happened since then that was Unthinkable
and
unpredictable the world is in many ways
an irreversibly different place than it
was conflicts are multiplying around our
borders Ukraine Gaza the caucuses the
Sahel the horrors of these wars are
appalling the pain suffered by innocent
civilians shakes the conscience of the
world and all of this is
happening against the backdrop of a huge
transformation such as the devastating
impact of climate change or the rise of
new technology
artificial intelligence for example that
could redefine not only our economies
but our societies and our
security these times of conflict and
change call for Europe to be even more
engaged on the global
stage and the size and the scale of
today today's events require that we act
and think
strategically even and specially
when the fog of war is thick and
emotions run
High our times require that our Union
makes full use of our foreign policy
potential ranging from the traditional
diplomacy to trade to humanitarian Aid
to investments just to name a
few and these are the principles that
have driven us so far so
engagement strategic thinking and unity
of
action and today I would like to focus
on three of the most strategic and
consequential issues we are currently
facing it is
Ukraine it is the Middle East and it is
China and of course I'll be happy to
take um q&as afterwards and to address
the other topics where I do not have the
time to elaborate on here in this uh key
note that I will
give let me start with
Ukraine I was there over the
weekend and the message that I heard
from everyone in ke is crystal
clear the people of Ukraine are Longing
To Join the European Union they believe
in Europe they trust Europe more than
ever
before and this is certainly because an
entire continent the European Union has
mobilized in support of Ukraine
but also because of the incredible work
of the EU staff in the country and I
want to pay tribute to them and take the
opportunity to pay tribute to all of you
all of our EU staff across the
world I just looked during my mandate
how many countries I visited I visited
37 countries outside the European Union
many of them several times
so I met plenty of you many of you I saw
it by my own eyes I listen to your
reports you know the Traditions I keep
on going there I learned from you the
latest developments on the ground and I
want to thank you for your tiess service
you are indeed in the best sense of the
word representing our Union and you can
be proud of
it
now back to
Ukraine Russia's brutal War now lasts
more than 600
days and on Saturday I spoke in the
fova and what I felt was yes 600 days of
war and bloodshed are exhausting without
any question but president zeny and the
Ukrainian people are as determined as on
the first day and let me tell you what
they told
me they basically said look at what we
have achieved Putin has failed on all
his strategic
objectives his main goal was regime
change he wanted to overthrow the
government in ke but not only has his
offensives on the capital completely
failed Ukraine's government is standing
strong bolstered by internal and
international
support the Rada the Ukrainian
Parliament is adopting far reaching
reforms that many had deemed impossible
before the
war and Ukraine is moving with ambition
and with determination on its path
toward the European
Union they tell
me that today more than ever before we
are Masters of our own
future and they are
right Russia wanted to erase Ukraine's
national
identity instead the war has forged
Ukraine's identity stronger than
before Russia wanted to weaken
NATO instead NATO is revitalized with
two new allies and defense spending
Rising across the European
Union Russia's Army has lost half of its
conventional
equipment and sacrificed over 100,000 of
their young
men Russian mercenaries have turned
against their masters or think of the
ones feared Russian Black Sea
Fleet
today thanks to the brave acts of the
ukrainians it has retreated from
blocking
Odessa and there are countless more
examples so even if the situation on the
ground is now evolving slowly one thing
is crystal
clear because of Ukraine's
resolve and because of our unwavering
support this war will remain a strategic
failure for the
Kremlin but we also
know that Putin's failure will not
automatically translate into Ukraine's
Victory so as the War drags on and as we
continue to cater for the daily needs of
ukrainians we must also try to focus on
the way forward and on what it means to
support Ukraine for as long as it
takes and I would like to suggest three
main objectives that we must
pursue first objective must be to
continue to work for a just and Lasting
peace not another Frozen
conflict no one wants peace more than
the Ukrainian
people so the main Pathway to achieve
this is President zelinsky's peace
formula and that is why we the
commission participated in all three
meetings of the National Security
advisers you remember Copenhagen jeda
and now
Malta more than 60 representatives are
working very hard to prepare a future
Ukraine peace Summit
so let me ask all of
you to keep on engaging to gather more
and more support for the peace formula
from countries across the world I know
it's not easy I know it is hard work but
in the essence in the end the whole
world would benefit from a just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine that has to be
our main
mission
second Ukraine needs long-term term
security we have to ensure a sustained
military force capable to defending
Ukraine
now and deterring Russian aggression in
the
future so that history does not repeat
itself this has of course strong
implications for our in defense
industry we must step up our production
capabilities and that is why we have
introduced ASAP the act in support of
ammunition production but we must must
of course look Beyond ammunition we have
to look at air defense crucial at the
moment being Maritime capabilities but
of course for the mid and longterm also
cyber space these are capabilities that
are European by Nature if you look at
them they require European
cooperation not only on research and
development but they require require
European cooperation on the industrial
front so we have to ensure now that no
industrial bottleneck prevents us from
protecting Europe and giving our full
support to
Ukraine it is a window of opportunity
now and I would urge us to take this
window of use this window of opportunity
because it would be a wind of
opportunity to be more decisive and take
more decisive steps
towards a genuine European Defense Union
this is a task I'm very much um uh I'm
very much supporting and working hard
for it my third
point the best way to give Ukraine
stability and prosperity in the mid and
long term is of
course membership in the European
Union just think about it to make
Ukraine
recover Europe is the
answer to strengthen Ukraine's democracy
even
further Europe is the
answer to protect Ukraine from future
interference Europe is the
answer and and this is very important
the reverse is also
true in a world where size and weight
matter it is clearly in Europe's
geostrategic interest to complete need
our
Union just think about it with over 500
million people living in a
free
Democratic prosperous
Union so history is calling again and
excellencies it is for Our Generation to
answer this
call dear
ambassadors this leads me to my second
point
on Israel and
Gaza there is no justification for the
horror that Hamas Unleashed against
innocent men women children and babies
on the 7th of
October in the wake of the worst mass
murder of Jews since the
Holocaust it is our moral duty to
demonstrate our full solidarity
with the people of
Israel Israel has the right to defend
itself in line with international law
and international humanitarian
law this is and continues to be the
essential starting
point and this is
also what gives us
credibility to discuss Israel's response
to Hamas ter
Terror but also to come forward with
ideas about a much needed political
solution building on our Legacy as
champions of the two- State
solution and that is why it was
necessary and
appropriate that so many European
leaders visited Israel in the wake of
the terrorist
attacks
supporting Israel is
essential and aiding civilians in Gaza
is essential
too the humanitarian situation is
dire the death toll and the suffering of
Palestinian civilians is
tragic and as policy makers we Face a
dreadful
dilemma Israel has the right to defend
itself
while Hamas bunkers hides Fighters and
stores
weapons below refugee camps and civilian
infrastructure Hamas is clearly using
innocent P Palestinians and hostages as
human
Shields it is horrific and it is pure
evil and our hearts bleed at the
images of small children pulled out from
under the
rubble all of
us as
democracies and as human
beings have a responsibility do
everything possible to protect civilians
who are Caught In Harm's
Way so while Israel has the right to
fight Hamas it is also
essential that it strives to avoid
civilian
casualties and to be as targeted as
possible
possible because every human life
matters be it Israeli or
Palestinian and this is Central to our
diplomatic Outreach in these days and
weeks we are currently focusing our
efforts in three main
directions the first one is humanitarian
support
two weeks ago we had already tripled our
Aid to
Gaza today I can announce that we are
further increasing the humanitarian Aid
to Gaza by another 25 million
EUR by doing so the European Union would
spend a total of 100 million euro in
humanitarian aid for the civilians in
Gaza and at the same
time we're working with Israel Egypt and
the United
Nations to let more convoys into Gaza
including through corridors and pauses
for humanitarian
needs Aid is now entering through the
ruffer border
crossing but the volumes remain too
small to match the massive humanitarian
needs in
Gaza our priority is to work with
Partners to reinforce Rua's logistic
capacities and at the same time we're
working on compliment complimentary
routes a maritime corridor from Cypress
for
example that would guarantee a sustained
regulated and robust flow of Aid and I
very much welcome the excellent
cooperation with President Nikos Christo
does and his
government our Union is the largest
humanitarian donor to Gaza and we will
keep pushing for our Aid to reach
civilian in need this can make the
difference between life and death for
thousands of
Palestinians and we will continue our
efforts to help evacuate EU citizens and
injured
Palestinians a second point is on
hostages of course member states are
leading the efforts to bring all
hostages to
safety this is one of the greatest
hostage crisis
in Europe's history and also for many
non-european
countries all of them must make it home
to their loved
ones and we will support member states
in every way
possible every single hostage
matters and their Capal should free them
and should free them
now my third point is we must do
everything in in our power to avoid a
regional
conflict the risk of spillover is
real but an escalation is not
inevitable it will require joint efforts
and Joint Visions for the future by the
United States by the European Union by
the Arab countries of course the United
Nations and others to achieve
this and today I would like to thank
especially
those among you who are posted in the
region for your tireless work to contain
the escalation I know it is going to be
hard and that's why we need all your
support to find a way
forward this Outreach to Regional
capitals will be even more important in
the coming weeks I know you've done a
tremendous work already but we have to
go on and we have to have a long breath
tomorrow I will welcome King Abdullah of
Jordan to Brussels to offer all our
support to this country as we're doing
of course right now already and
yesterday I spoke to president alisi of
course also to exchange on the situation
and how we can support Egypt in these
difficult
times and at the same time and that is
important we have to work on
normalization between Israel and its
neighbors and this normalization can
continue and it must continue we all
know that hammer wanted to destroy that
this historic
rapmon but the rapmon is not only
historic it also brings lots of Hope and
economic prosperity to the region so
it's very
tangible an example just two months ago
you might perhaps recall we signed in da
I would say the most ambitious project
of Our Generation
it is the Europe Middle East India
economic
Corridor just think about it this
Corridor will be the most direct
connection that we have to date between
Europe
Israel
Jordan Saudi Arabia the Emirates and
then India just think about this rail
data electricity and green hydrogen
and all of them working
together these are the state-of-the-art
connections of the world tomorrow of
tomorrow and it is not only a
fascinating economic bridge this is too
but it is also a bridge most importantly
between
people between cultures of course
civilizations and if it works it will
bring along new connections and you know
it also new connections bring new
friendships
and this could bring a common
perspective to a very troubled
region millions of people all across the
world feel that the Middle East is
stuck in a spiral of endless
conflict where violence only leads to
more
violence but this does not have to be
the
case as we deal with the urgency of
today we must also make the effort to
think about tomorrow and I know all of
you as
allies to imagine what a lasting peace
may look
like yes and even in these times to
restore hope for Palestinians and
Israelis and for this they need a
perspective and the perspective is the
two-state
solution of course in the end Israelis
and Palestinians have to agree agree
they have to agree on the way forward
but I believe we as a part of the
international
effort must also cont contribute we have
a role to play by putting forward some
basic principles for example for the day
after that could help find common
ground and let me a little bit elaborate
on this
one first of
all Gaza can be no safe heaven for
terrorists we know what happened after
the previous Gaza
Wars Hamas immediately started
rebuilding its Arsenal and preparing for
the next
conflict this cannot be the case any
longer so different ideas are being
discussed on how this can be ensured
including an International Peace Force
Under un
mandate second
this
implies that the terrorist organization
Hamas cannot control or govern
Gaza there should be only one
Palestinian
Authority and one Palestinian
State
third there can be no long-term Israeli
security presence in
Gaza Gaza is an essential part of any
future Palestinian
State
fourth very important no forc
displacement of Palestinians from
Gaza this would only be a recipe for
more Regional
instability and
finally no sustained blockade of
Gaza this policy has not
worked Hamas has continued to build up
its Arsenal while the economy of Gaza
has collapsed so it's just the opposite
of what we
wanted 70% of young people in Gaza are
jobless
70% and this can only lead to more
radicalization we all know it here in
the
room so any future Palestinian state
must be
viable also from an economic point of
view and Europe stands ready to work
with all people and countries in this
region to make this happen
excellencies all of this may be or may
look overly ambitious as the war still
rages on but I think we must spare no
effort to keep the hope
alive to find a lasting
solution based on two
states living side by side in peace and
in
security so it is again time for an
international
effort towards peace in the Middle East
and we will play our
part thear
ambassadors I started by saying that the
conflicts in
Europe the Middle East or Africa should
not mask our other challenges we face
whether linked to climate or
digital trade or e Economic
Security and in fact this
instability should make us focus our
minds on the key relationships we have
across the
world our relationship with
China is one of the most intricate and
important anywhere in the
world and how we manage
it will be a determining factor for our
future future economic prosperity and
National
Security in these turbulent times there
is strong need for strategic stability
in how we deal with China we must get
China
right we must recognize that there is an
explicit element of rivalry in our
relationship the Chinese Communist
party's clear goal is is a systemic
change of the international order of
course with China at its
Center we've seen it with China's
positions in multilateral
bodies which show its determination to
promote an alternative vision of the
world
order but this rivalry can be
constructive not
hostile and this is why we need
functioning channels of communication
and high high level diplomacy this is
what I have called drisking through
diplomacy and this is why we have
invested in intensive dialogues with
Beijing from our high level I think it
was four high level dialogues now to the
upcoming EU China Summit that we will
have in a couple of
weeks so cooperation with China on
global issues is
possible and it is
happening we see it also in the fight
against climate change there is room to
Define together common rules and
solution to challenges we all
share but working in the confines of the
rules-based system also means respecting
it across the board for instance the
rules of the WTO matter as much as other
multilateral rules like the UN
convention on on the law on the of the
sea and today we must
recognize that China's view on the
Global Security
architecture are not by default aligned
with
ours just think about Ukraine China says
it upholds the UN
Charter but it does not distance itself
from Russia's war of
aggression so the way forward is to keep
engaging with Beijing so that the
support to Russia remains as limited as
possible but also to make clear and
that's important that the way China
positions itself on the Russian war will
of course Define our mutual
relationship the same is true for other
theaters which are increasingly
linked China states that it is
impartial and favors peaceful Solutions
while enabling and supporting some of
the world's most destabilizing
forces and yet China and Europe have a
shared interest in stability in the
Middle East so every measure of
influence that Beijing has on Hamas and
Iran needs to be used to prevent further
escalation they have to play their
role and if we widen our lens we're
watching very closely the situation in
the South China
Sea they affect not just our partners in
the region such as the Philippines but
of course our Global
interests China's actions impact our
security and sovereignity and our
prosperity and we have to be very Frank
on this as a foundation for a
constructive
relationship we must also be clear eyed
on how China's Global posture is
changing we see a strong push to make
China less dependent on the world and
the world more dependent on China so
geopolitics and geoeconomics cannot be
seen as separate
anymore by now China is our most
important trading partner in terms of
goods we should not forget that but at
the same
time concerns about unfair
and at times predatory practices
distorting our own single Market are
absolutely tangible and Rising
measurable for instance China has often
resorted to trade
coercion boycotts of European goods and
Export controls on critical raw
materials this shows that while we do
not want to decouple from China we do
need to drisk parts of our
relationship drisk not de couple is by
now a strategy accepted by all major
Western
partners and part of the work has to
happen here in the European
Union and we have already come quite a
long way think about our new trade
defense
instruments or our investigation on
Chinese electric
vehicles but the global dimension
I of drisking is just as
important our approach has found broad
support from Key Partners from Japan to
Canada from the United States to
Australia and countries all around the
world want to work with Europe that's a
good
news some of them are also overly
depending themselves on a single country
for essential Supply
chains and they care about their own
Economic Security just like we do
it others for example want to develop
local Industries for processing and
refining instead of just shipping their
resources abroad so there are multiple
interests to work with
us and Europe's offer is truly
unique with
clear and very precise and transparent
benefits for both sides this is the
heart of what what I would say of global
gateway our new way to partner with
third countries abroad we had just the
recent global gateway forum for instance
there we have signed a number of
impressive new projects across the world
we have now 92 Flagship progress Pro
projects that we are pursuing across the
world and um a few examples for example
take the trans African Corridor it will
not only connect land locked regions in
the DRC and Zambia to Global markets but
it will also to invest in local value
chains and in skills for the local
Workforce or take our investment road
map with Namibia to develop a local
industry for green hydrogen and critical
raw
materials our business plan is so
attractive that countries from Colombia
to Kazakhstan from maania to Vietnam now
all are asking to work with us on
similar projects so word is spreading
that is good and these are all
investments in prosperity for our
partners of course at I level but as
well in the European Economic Security
and our own
Prosperity as team
Europe and that's the difference we have
the size and we have the financial power
to bring about real
change and we are finally making use of
our massive economic Assets in a much
more strategic way dear
ambassadors whether we Face a rogue
Russia a boiling Middle East or a
fragmented global
economy the core of Europe's response
must stay the same we need to act
together aligning our
interests and our
values because what happens to democracy
and freedom peace and Security in one
part of the world of course directly
affects the lives of Europeans here in
our European
Union we have a lot we can draw
on Europe's greatest strength lies in
the diversity of the assets we can
mobilize from Aid to trade from
sanctions to Investments you just name
it and you you the
ambassadors you play such a central and
crucial
role our delegations are the hubs of our
external
action in a world where size and weight
does matter we must put the full force
of our Union at the service of our
values peace security and
prosperity so let me thank you all for
your dedicated service to our Union and
let me with wish you an excellent
ambassador's week here in Brussels thank
you very much for your
[Applause]
[Music]
attention